[Music]
excellent work take pride in your
accomplishments
[Music]
hey everyone how's it going my name is
Jake I'm here with Nick and what are we
gonna play hey what's up we're playing a
really cool game called Call of Duty
World War two ever heard of it
game comes out tomorrow we got an
advance copy and now the servers are
live so we're gonna kind of be jumping
around here we're gonna start with we're
gonna start with the campaign we'll
probably do a mission from the campaign
we're not gonna do something super light
but we're not gonna do d-day because
that's how it starts and I think people
have mostly seen that so we'll play
mission the campaign we're gonna go on
to zombies and then we're gonna do
multiplayer we're also gonna do some of
the pits and Nick and I are gonna battle
it out see who's better in that a lot a
lot of new stuff that's out here the new
Cod I'm thinking we go stronghold here
so we'll go with the third July 26 we
rolled up a lot of backstory I closed my
own but ended up having the dream again
yeah that's good
so basically what's going on here is
we're gonna see a little cinematic to
start it's gonna introduce some of the
characters and here we go
same dream huh pretty much can't seem to
shake it
I'm good now you get some rest
no I have to show Pearson I'm ready I
don't care what he says you ain't got
nothing to prove
yeah well I'm tired of taking a [ __ ]
back home you want to settle something
you do it head-on it's the only way to
earn respect I understand that believe
me a man has to fight his own battles
respect don't mean a lot if you get
yourself killed just glad you got my
back besides good old st. Michael's
watching over us so we got nothing to
worry about that realize you guys
believed in that stuff I'll take all the
help I can get these do your best girl
tell me about that dreams meaning what
wolves had been killing our cattle me
and my older brother Paul were hunting
them when we got corn sorry Paul listen
good kid it's only natural to be scared
[Music]
we need to head home baby brother from
that day on I swore I'd never let Paul
down again but now it's not just him I
got to live up to its Pearson
so that's main character red that's who
you play as our job is to lay down
suppressive fire from that church any
questions
good save them up Stiles you win a gold
star let's go that's Pearson I don't
remember that actor's name but he is
pretty great almost as great as the
Thompson rifle I love the Thompson like
favorites gun one of the great oh yeah
the bar the bar I love the bar so just
the reviews up correct no the review
will be live 9 p.m. tonight
so keep an eye on that but all kind of
streaming gameplay a little bit of some
wiki stuff that's all live now so be
sure to take a look check out some of
that stuff on site right now and I
believe it's coming up on YouTube slowly
I'm gay sloth calm we have an in-depth
look at the HQ we have a look at the
very first Normandy mission and we have
a look at a hardcore domination game
play from multiplayer so if you guys
want to check some of that stuff out
we'll probably go over a lot of that
stuff here on this stream but if you're
imagine of course we'll also be checking
the chat to answer questions so if
there's anything you you want to ask
just drop it in there I'll be sure to
get to it and like Nick said the review
isn't up so I don't think he necessarily
say how we feel we can give impressions
we have questions max yep so I'll go
I'll go ahead and give some initial
impressions I had a lot of time to play
the
at a review event recently and I really
like it
I've been having a blast there's a lot
of new ways to play there's a lot of new
it's gone back to a lot of the classic
styles so you can tell my health goes
back to the way things were in the old
Cod's where you get to only in campaign
mode only in campaign yeah and
multiplayer it's still the regenerating
health and even in zombies it's
regenerating yeah yeah zombies is cool
yo is the campaign yet is this is about
what do you say a third of the way
through maybe this is only the third
mission maybe like a fourth of the way
okay I did we skip what we've skipped so
far story-wise is we skipped the d-day
invasion which is kind of a staple for
world war ii games and we skipped kind
of the fight through the beach so we're
in March I think it's Margaery or
majorie France and so what we're doing
is we're trying to shoot this oh my god
we're trying to take this town to like
protect it so we have a stronghold as we
like push towards the Rhine so I'm using
health packs and this is how you use
kind of your squadmates those Essman
here can give me help ask he sends me a
health pack and then I can just go ahead
open it up use it
Pearson allows me to get orders and
recon and I yellow which is another
squad mate lets me get mortar strikes
let's see if I can get over to got a
couple questions here I'm gonna
interrupt you just to answer some of
these though it says what constantly
playing on this is ps4 when's it coming
to PC same day Friday November 3rd is
the beginning like Saving Private Ryan
yes it is I think I would say it's
probably I don't know if it's my
favorite d-day experience in a videogame
but it's definitely one of the cooler
ones and then oh shoot grenade I die but
but you can't say it or but can you say
is it more of the same Cod we've
received it yeah I think when it comes
down to it like you know what you're
gonna get this is a Call of Duty game
above all but
it does have little changes here and
there that are kind of nice nods to
previous games and it's also just like a
nice change of palette like I was
getting really sick of the like I was
like yeah all that junk like got
tiresome but I mean you know it's still
Call of Duty yeah it's still it's so
called duty at the end of the day but I
think I think they took a lot of
suggestions from the community and
obviously I think that kind of the way
that battlefield one went back in time I
think that influenced a lot of people's
wants for shooters a lot of people think
I was going to talk about how people
think that people got tired I guess of
world war two shooters and I think this
is the right time to go back yeah I
think because we haven't really had one
in a long time except for like the
sniper League games yeah Sniper Elite
they're the ones that we're third-person
World War two I think so yeah right and
there's been a couple other ones as well
but I feel like there hasn't been a
triple a blockbuster World War two game
in a very long time
this one is exciting I really enjoy the
campaign I also think that zombies we
leave commies is cool we've gone the
streak for a while I feel like where a
lot of these zombies games were very
satirical and kind of comedic and now
it's more so it's kind of has like a
survival horror tone to it which is
totally different compared to like the
80s version where Hasselhoff is like DJs
and stuff and I think that's a good
thing a couple more questions here when
is the review out we already mentioned
this but I just guess you're tuning in
now it's at 9 p.m. tonight
Pacific correct Pacific Pacific up so
midnight your time so launch time on the
East Coast if you're in and then someone
says where the aimbot is that I think he
came back okay
this is campaign so there aren't any in
hitting bodies but if you're talking
about like the little white lines that
aim it's not a campaign but it isn't
multiplayer yeah which I like I was
saying this yesterday I'm usually not
one who plays like no HUD but I would
love it if the campaign had no hutch
it's so it goes through that authentic
feel for everything yeah got like your
I'd rather like fire and then run out of
ammo and like have to actually reload
rather than it do it for you it's also a
very pretty game to be honest it is very
pretty the cinematics are gorgeous I
thought someone says is the game out
today or next week it comes out tonight
if you're on it comes out tonight
but any Eastern you I'm pretty sure some
places might have some midnight openings
let's see they're always looking for
mementos but yeah you can get it tonight
it's pretty exciting but early tomorrow
early tomorrow if you're on the East
Coast if you're in the US or if you're
in West Coast yep preload B is for what
time Australia out I'm not gonna do that
math usually Jesus usually earlier yeah
say like you could probably expect it
the second instead of the third ah no no
yes I don't know I yet i I'm not gonna
do that math right now can't be too sure
where's the what things are different
from this is a good question what things
are different from old Call of Duty
World War two games is from sorry I'm
probably mispronouncing this and I can't
really see Amrit Samant Samanta so what
what kind of makes this remind us of the
old games I guess what's the different
from like what's this between this Call
of Duty World War 2 and Call of Duty 2
or 3-year Call of Duty finest hour big
dread oh man
John Luke one of our video producers
would be the expert since he's been
doing history of which you should also
keep an eye out for man and what are the
biggest differences I think the biggest
difference campaign wise is the way that
you use your squad mates
so each squad mate has kind of a
specific role and a specific job and
they kind of benefit you through but
it's kind of determined by how many
kills you get there's also gamified if
she was kind of shallow but it's a nice
little touch yeah I I've played I think
I've played every single Call of Duty
from finest hour I'm actually to play
black ops 3 or infinite warfare I played
a little bit unfair but I think the
biggest difference that I think is those
older World War 2 Call of Duty games
like I mean I mean there was a huge step
with Call of Duty 4 yeah and I think
this game takes a lot of those
improvements from for and on and kind of
brings it back to this world war 2
setting so so it basically seems like a
more refined version interview campaign
wise you can tell there's a much more
focus on stronger storytelling because
if you played those other ones there was
story but it was it was basically like
set piece to set piece and you got a
little set up usually it was in the form
of like a map and pictures if someone
was like describe it yeah the event and
this is this still has that but it's
more like I don't know like you saw when
we started there was there was more
characterization yep and they're you
know obviously in a Call of Duty game
it's gonna be a little slow to get the
to kind of get the story going because
they there's a lot of things that this
game focuses on aside from the story
whether it's multiplayer zombies but
if you do play through the whole
campaign it does have some pretty cool
twist some interesting endings that
aren't like you know every single World
War two game we've had in the past
cyborg man wants to know is there a
vehicle sequence like old called during
world war ii games called ut3 big red
one head tank missions I have only
played three for missions but there has
been a vehicle mission I won't say what
you're driving but I'm sure Nick there's
even more than that there are a few not
as many as some of the former titles but
there are definitely vehicle missions
yeah and the one I played was pretty fun
it was pretty fun yeah there is one I
won't say any details but it's towards
the end of the game and it is awesome it
is very satisfying it it all isn't like
applicable to the big story which is
awesome cyborg man says big red one also
had a b-25 bomber mission which was cool
yeah that mission was dope I I really
liked big red one my lips will seize
we'll forget about that one but that was
a that was a good game
all right oh they're shooting the church
get out of here
oh no you died Nick never reminds me of
the scene where the clock is falling and
uncharted it does they have these new
quick sequences which are kind of cool
I think they asked the story not a fan
cuz usually I'm texting or something
yeah I like you guys did an article
about the length of the game how long is
it Nick you finish the game you can
probably answer this one so I finished
the game and I kind of took my time
looking for mementos and looking for
side stuff and it took me about seven
hours so it's a typical typical length I
feel like for a Call of Duty game
McKell concepción who played it to
review event who also he also took his
time it took him I think six hours 23
minutes according to the article B
should definitely check out Miguel's
article because oh what I was trying to
take that mg got a GTFO there's uh try
to get it this time give it to me
there's also the first mission the first
complete mission gameplays in there as
well for you guys to check out damn one
of that mg didn't get it
whoa
great scene it's ready turn up the
volumes a little bit you see wings on me
private no sergeant that's because I'm
not your fairy [ __ ] godmother
damnit I just lost two good men in there
then we gotta pull it together and take
out those guns come on I know that seems
easy he's he's really good in this game
his acting is a fan some of the other
ones are they can be a little bit
cringe-worthy but can't think the
actor's name isn't if anyone the
comments can they hooked me up with his
name
I know he's in transformers so a couple
questions here as well don't you think
it's time there could be destructible
scenarios and environments and call of
duty they kind of tried that with goats
but they kind of half-assed it
and I didn't think it was very good I
don't yeah I'd like to stressful
environments but I totally get why there
are a bit but not to the extent that
battlefield is for sure yeah they're
like scripted right there yeah they're
very scripted and it's like specific
missions that they're next question is
is it hard to get the platinum trophy on
ps4 I don't know if you taking a look at
that I haven't started or tried yet I
imagine like most Call of Duty's at
least actually I don't even know anymore
most Call of Duty's don't give you
trophies and achievements for
multiplayer modes it's all single-player
focus so I imagine like if you do the
campaign on the hardest difficulty and
then you collect make sure to collect
everything you probably get it pretty
quickly I don't know if there's things
and zombies - that's probably something
yeah I've done the whole campaign plus a
lot of the mementos and I know
according to oh shoot those are not our
according to my Oh God heal heal heal
according to my PSN I was at 25 percent
so would you play it on your first you
first go through I played it on regular
just because the rush through the review
okay so we've got a couple questions how
do you rate the graphics or how do you
compare the graphics like it doesn't
look as photorealistic but I think that
battlefront looks great that's nice like
dice stuff always looks so good
they did a really fantastic job Josh
josh Josh Duhamel Josh Duhamel thank you
that's who it is
they did a fantastic job with their cuff
scenes in this game and also kind of the
it's not really it's like the in in
gameplay cutscenes they are really
detailed really good and like the
characterization and like facial
animations look great so I don't know
what they did with mocap this year but
they stepped it even though I didn't
play that much infinite warfare and that
game also looked really good so I guess
I'm probably just behind the times cod
was so this one probably looks as good
as the last one but I think it looks
better I didn't I did not finish the
campaign for the last one I don't know
what it was about kind of the future
shooters I think it was during the time
when titanfall was out it was yeah I so
I like the campaign in the last one I
really liked how they kind of had that
map where you can like pick your mission
I thought that was really cool yeah kind
of bum they got rid of it to be honest
does it add a lot of depth to it but
still yeah I couldn't get through that
game and I'll probably get through this
game just because it's so cool seeing
all these different battlefields brought
to life I hope the next game will
include a Pacific Peter like world blue
I agree I agree
I so my best guess is if this game does
well I have a feeling sledgehammer I'll
probably continue it's like they'll
probably be the developers like yep
and I would imagine like if that is the
case we'll probably get we'll probably
get a specific I do
I think sledgehammer obviously but I
have a funny feeling that they have some
plans or Dean sources good cop bad cop
sergeant terrors the nice one Pierson
the scary I've been way too easy now
we're gonna find out what you really may
have thanks Josh Duhamel we brought him
Hitler's head on a silver platter he
complained about the shine we keep
fighting like we did today we'll be over
in no time
that's why we got to make the big plays
now all right oh man so that was the
third mission from call duty World War
two two's story modes or we're gonna
stop here just because we've weird
stronghold spoil anything else you guys
but that was the story so now we're
going to some of you just get me out of
here and get back to the main menu and
we're gonna do some zombies all right
I'm pretty excited about I think I'm
gonna join in on this as well so keep
leaving comments we'll be checking the
comments hopefully not or I mean
hopefully just as frequent frequently
but you know zombies can be intense so
give me a minute to get this set up okay
all right I'll get us set up so zambese
pretty interesting stuff it's very
different than the previous version this
kind of go back it goes back to the Nazi
Zombies root kind of their core gameplay
where it was horror when it first came
out and right that was world at war when
the first one world at war was the first
one and yes and it's yeah so the first
map that they released was just that I
think it was knocked around
Toton and it was
yeah but that was the that one was just
one house there were no characters it
was very not I don't wanna say grounded
because this definitely isn't grounded
it was kind of ridiculous campy but like
it wasn't until after that where they
started introducing you know like
characters and like comedy to the whole
thing yep um let's see I want to invite
you make sure you get signed in so
there's a prologue we're not going to
play it now look maybe in the next
couple days for a feature video feature
on Nazi Zombies for COD but there's
prologue it can I introduce the story I
give a little backstory send me an
invite while you're doing it okay you
ready
so essentially there is a group of not
cheesy soldiers hopefully it's on camera
I can't tell cuz I don't have a feed
well if it is hi how are ya so
essentially there's this soldier that
has did you get it yeah
in current game session
so there's get out of this so I can go
back to a secret there we go yeah
there's this Oh No
unable to join I wonder if we're not
live yet no cuz we connected the online
services hmm okay let me try to invite
you again I can always try as well let's
see sorry guys still day one trying to
figure out who's online who's not trying
to see what things are up but sorry I
start keep getting tracked off there is
basically this story where one of the
German soldiers knows where the secret
area with experiments is going on and so
we're tasked with trying to go and
figure out oh I have to go back to the
main thing right bro show us multiplayer
gun please we'll get to that we're gonna
do we're gonna do a couple rounds
zombies we get to that let's see
joining game session fingers crossed so
what we're tasks is we're trying to
figure out what they're hiding in the
secret vault dang I don't think we're
live yet I think we're alive I just
don't think it's
shoot all right well I'll happen it was
social so long match just so we dang
hopefully we can link up at least in
multiplayer or I'll do a little solo
match just so you guys can see the final
Reich and then alright so basically I'm
going to go with these different
loadouts so I'm gonna go with the medic
class the meta cross allows me to use
camouflage and so we're waiting for
other players
oh is this gonna connect me with others
Oh interesting
I don't know if there are any other so
I'm gonna do a solo match apologies
custom Matt okay I should be good now
alright where we're going sorry
one thing about zombies is camera looks
weird
one thing about zombies is that it is
very not very different than other ones
but there are some big changes what are
you want to talk about some of those so
I think the biggest change is that this
new zombies reminds me a lot of
Destiny's raid where there's a specific
order in which you have to do things and
yes that was the situation in the past
as well but this kind of this is the
first time where the story kind of
progresses and you have to do things as
a team so it's a little bit different in
that sense than in the past and then the
biggest thing is that they won't let
survival-horror so if a zombie sneaks up
behind you you're gonna hear like a loud
crashing sound like that that's gonna
try to scare you
there's a lot of like jump scares we'll
try to pop out and spooky ax drop
concealing comes before
shovel here they don't tell you how to
do anything as well they'll tell you
what your objective is but it's up to
you to yeah
locate the bunker entrance so there's
the bunker entrance
that's essentially what the story comes
behind you're trying to get in here
that's about as far as I made it inside
then I died shortly after
guys I have decision Call of Duty World
War two those are very different games
oh my god that was embarrassing I was
trying to turn the thing and also reach
out my bad I'll start over those dumb so
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
turn three knobs within like the first
three set like the first round these if
I don't get those knobs it gets too
overwhelmed yeah we can't actually you
know what let's do that that's actually
better alright Jake and I will play if
that's cool with everyone in the chat I
remember blackops2 having celebrity
actors yeah it did
okie dokie so I want to go leave the
lobby go to custom words
hit social hit triangle I thought I saw
something when I was setting it up Oh
Eddie controller for split screen it's
gonna need me just sign in let's forget
it no no dice
actually hold on let me try one more
time because I might just feel the new
user and guests let's see
chats probably mad at me I'm sorry I'm
not focused hearing zombies all right
there we go place guest do not sign in
third a seat right there nice Haley sees
my dr. steve brule icon big fan of dr.
Brule I don't know if I'm in or not I
don't think I am go back map final rake
lobby
no it says one on four go go back again
there was that thing where it said uh
yeah it's gonna have you sign in there
okay
hit hit X go do custom match game rules
baby I don't see it I'm just gonna hop
in all right I don't know what it is all
right I'll focus this time
awesome show guys great job with the
stream sorry and the stream for watching
probably he's probably a facetious and
you can't have probably sorry and this
dream our bed still day one stuff so
we're trying to even though it's not
even d1 we're trying to figure out what
you live what we can do what we can't do
sorry so I'm gonna try to do a couple
the first kind of objectives so its
objective based so the first thing you
want to do is turn on all the knobs then
once you do that then you could turn the
power to get into the sewer system and
the sewers you can turn on a generator
and it goes on and on and on from there
during the review event we played for
about an hour and 10 minutes total made
it - I think wave 22 on a 4 player co-op
and the devs told us we were only about
20% in which is a little scary because
it must mean there's a lot of Secrets
you have to figure out at launch there's
only gonna be two different zombies
multiplayer multiplet we're actually
just in general two zombie maps one is
rised about two maps but almost every
Call of Duty game launches with two it
has one that you start with and then one
you unlock when you complete the
campaign yep so the first one is this
one which is the very long very wide
open map that is kind of the objective
based one where you want to do kind of a
rate style things with your friends
there's the first ones on and then the
second one is
house it's a Bavarian house and you have
to just survive which is like classic
zombies there's also this really Chris
then once I have one stuff do it you can
decapitate them with the shovel which is
pretty satisfying
all right so also I don't know if this
strategies in the past if you try to
keep one zombie alive and do a lot of
the objectives they'll eventually it'll
eventually decompose and die that kind
of happened before like it was weird
when it would out of character alright
so well I'm one alive I'm going to
quickly try to get this third part okay
alright so this is the third valve no
one's around me everyone wants to see
Tennant I think the British dude
or not British dude the Irish dude
they're so gross and you know they're
coming
oh wow
we're gonna go to multiplayer because
I'm doing a poor showing wow this is bad
oh wow okay
multiplayer does I need to play with
others well that didn't go well damn
alright you couldn't get two player to
work that sucks that I can't play with
others because I'm lousy alone alright
so let's see if let's try again if we
can get you and Scottish alright sorry
guys
zombies I was really hoping we're gonna
be able to co-op obviously you can go
really far in solo but me trying to do
three things at a time not working for
me don't worry about chat I'll be
looking at chat you just play okay um so
what we're gonna do now is if you guys
want me to go through all the weapons I
saw some comments that we're asking us
to go through all the weapons some what
I do here I do it quick so we can go
through that and then hopefully Jay can
hop into the HQ which is the hub world
and we can kind of work together and do
some challenges alright so we are in the
hub world now so this is the HQ it's
everything from picking up orders to
prestiging there is a gun range over
here that's where you pick up mail over
here is a theater in the theater you can
actually watch what is it like live pro
gaming leagues we're just kind of cool
got another question or not really a
question but someone's saying zombie
mode is too dark you can probably change
brightness if it is too dark you might
also just be the stream but it seemed
yeah Mayon you can you be out for Call
of Duty World War 2 tonight at 9
now I'm Pacific game launches so you can
read it and who are you here oh I hope
this works
I'm fingers crossed I'm a little bummed
that we weren't able to get into zombies
together send you an invite can I accept
it here you can send me an invite to let
me try oh all right inviting our buddy
Jake here and hopefully if he can accept
we're gonna do this is the 1v1 pit we're
gonna pit you against your friends and
it's kind of a fun little way to play
together competitively air
I can try inviting you but it'd probably
be it's gonna be the same thing it's
probably NAT dang and I don't think
anyone is in the queue yet hmm I wish
somebody would come play with me
No so there leaderboards around here
this is the scorestreak training range
it's where you can test out every single
score streak before you purchase them
you can also get the zombies in HQ you
want to come down here you can do
zombies multiplayer from down there so
everything is connected in the hub world
so you don't have to worry about getting
anywhere I'm gonna just go ahead and hop
in alright yeah I don't think it's gonna
work I'm just gonna go back to to a
public match let's try to do war this
war is one of the new modes that's kind
of objective based and it's um it
reminds me of Rush from battlefields one
yeah it's like a smaller scale rush yeah
shoot I was really hoping that we were
gonna be able to do some stuff online
doesn't look like we can get online and
play with random strangers but we can't
play with each other just yet
so you guys have already seen if you've
seen the beta you played the beta you
already know operation breakout so this
isn't one of the new maps hopefully
after this one finishes it'll either
give us Operation Neptune or we'll get
operation Griffin
so Griffin is in the snow Neptune is
basically the Normandy invasion serious
question here war what is it good for
absolutely nothing that's the answer uh
is the game actually out no comes out
tonight at 9 p.m. Pacific if you're not
sick soon as it starts they already
pushed the point I get a run back is
there only nine multiplayer maps thanks
there I'm not quite sure on the dot I
want to say nine but I also want to say
seven so I am not I'm not positive so
don't hold me to it time to kill us to
shorten my liking
yeah it's pretty short I think man I
this is fun
but I love Destiny's PvP so way more
than I thought I would like it kind of
just makes me want to play more
Destiny's PvP when I play it beta on PC
ran like [ __ ] for this game I never
played them Michael hi I'm did play it
on PC and he said there were some issues
I'm not quite sure I have not personally
played it on PC just yet because we
haven't gotten codes for it yeah I've
only been playing on PlayStation 4 Pro
and it's it's been good so far
Chris Hawk asks can you play against
bots I'm pretty sure you can I think so
I remember Miguel mentioning you could
do that
yeah yeah I'm pretty sure you can I'm
pretty sure Miguel just testing out all
the maps played through all of them and
he played through them with box yep
definitely be sure to be sure to take a
look at Miguel's review and it goes
alive at 9 p.m. it's pretty in-depth
it's one of our one of our longer
reviews this so this map right here this
is like this sniper choke point and that
is one of the most popular spots where
you shoot through the window of the car
so the Allies are trying to it's not a
complete openness there so the Allies
are trying to push through and build the
bridge we're trying to stop them
they're mg s in these towers but there's
literally no point in getting them he's
as soon as you get in gets night what
you're doing all these windows are
really dangerous just sitting there
waiting for min sometimes like to sneak
down here but you can't go too far
because then you go across the map
hello damn what the heck okay sick I'm
hoping that after this one it doesn't
switch us to the other side cuz a lot of
people have already seen this particular
war mode and there's a lot of new ones
that are pretty cool there's one
operation d-day yep d-day is really cool
operation Griffin is my favorite it's
also kind of a tank pushing one where
you want to push the tank all the way
across the whole way oh shoot some line
the enemy is feeding a breach let's see
let's see let's see this is probably bad
idea isn't it respond Alain all game
modes ah not for deathmatch
I don't believe or if it is it's a lot
shorter all right now we're groovin how
we're groovin okay until that happened
all right we got time
yeah well we'll get to the other half
are the other two modes they're only
three so I think this is the biggest
drawback to Call of Duty is that the
three this is my favorite mode I think
for multiplayer and it only comes with
three different through different Maps I
know that they've promised
they've definitely promised some more
modes in the future in different Maps
but it's only launching with three
someone asks yes Cosmetics only I think
it's it's fine I I know a lot of people
the topic of conversation yesterday was
that the loot boxes drop on in the front
and kind of like in the HQ so other
people can see it I don't necessarily
think that's really a big negative I
understand that people are saying that
like it forces other people to see what
other people are getting and then
whoa I just think it looks bad I don't
really care about other people seeing it
cuz like you're gonna tell your friends
anyway right yeah that's what I'm saying
that's that's you know people are like
oh it's you know it's tacky and I was
like well honestly like if I get
something cool in cop or anakata
overwatch I automatically whoa I
automatically run out and tweet it so
I'm like oh yo check it out I got this
you know six aria 80s theme also that
event end I didn't get that skin shoot
so I don't really see the difference but
I understand why people might be upset
but yes strictly it is strictly cosmetic
is across the line he's supposed to be I
think that's across our line so he must
be always cheese yeah damn it turn
cosmetics and loot box
yeah Nicholas mentioned it's only it's
only cosmetics you're not gonna be
getting weapons in that and honestly you
you get a fair amount of loot like loot
crate's and stuff you get a fair amount
of them just a shoot there is as is
zombies is where things are game
changers zombies crates are really
valuable so obviously there are things
like like new like the nuke and also
insta kill and stuff like that so those
things you can only get through loop
boxes and they're one-time use so when
you use them in one round they're gone
the next round Jesus
people are going off this is brutal
whether or not Nintendo is a success
I'm not gonna comment too much on that
except fish for D s was the highest
selling console or handheld oh shoot
we're hearing we're hearing game people
talking I was also gonna say I couldn't
get through that door but anyway this is
an unintended stream this is all about
call of duty if you have any questions
about Call of Duty's we're happy to
answer them as long as you don't ask us
what we'd score this game because we
can't say that but the review will be up
later tonight if you are enjoying the
stream make sure to subscribe and we do
stream every day Monday through Friday
at 11:00 a.m. we start a little bit
early today just because we're gonna
jump on that Call of Duty embargo so you
guys can see this as soon as possible
yep that's why we're here early hanging
out where's my squad let's please take
this come on boys oh damn squad on me uh
I can get this door whoa what was that
don't know damn sniper are we guys
fifty-four percent actually you know
what I would be okay with us failing
here so that we can move on to a
different map see I can't damn Fontbonne
losers oh wow that's why we're on
does this have online split-screen
multiplayer it deadly don't believe so I
do not believe so the other ones have
recently
it definitely has split-screen zombies
are why we couldn't figure it out
definitely not multiplayer of maybe
local you can do split-screen
well you look I'm not gonna plug in but
I bet we can luck yeah we can least
answer that question yeah actually maybe
with headquarters now maybe tough to do
something like that yeah I'm kind of
bummed uh 1v1 is is my personal
highlight for this game yeah here we go
operation Neptune this is the d-day war
mode this is the second of the three so
you've seen the og one that was in the
beta this is the new one there's one
more after this time to go oh shoot I'm
not gonna read this guy's name but he
says is it worth the $60 price so like I
said I don't think we can outright say
whether or not we think it is however it
seems like there's a lot to do in this
game we could at least say that like how
long have you played now how many hours
you think you've played ahaha played a
fair amount and you plan on one more so
just like depends like its its Call of
Duty like if you think if you think
you'll finish single-player and you'll
still be wanting to play multiplayer
zombie yeah if if you're only in it for
the campaign I'd probably wait until the
price drops cuz like I mean six hours
for $60 I don't know if that's worth it
but if you're into the campaign if
you're into the the multiplayer then
you're gonna playing this for possibly
that was sick so is that good work they
must not know this map yet really like a
lot of these guys are bought so I'm not
shooting them say that's a bot these
guys do they are not BOTS
yeah Boston warmup so our bots added to
fill other spaces or BOTS just there to
make it seem like there's a bigger
attack but bots are there to make it
look like d-day because it would only be
six people rushing the beach versus like
which all these rain random random a
whole man that's the other thing this is
another spot where it's just like sniper
galore
so each I would say each round of war
mode there's a specific round that has
sniping so in Neptune is the first round
in the one we just played that I'm the
bridge we're getting the name it's the
bridge that's the middle point and it's
also the first round in damn and it's
also the first round same person whose
name I won't regime says do you think
that sledgehammer will support the PC
community more with this game it's yeah
yeah they I know Michael Condrey we had
a chance to kind of talk to him I think
Miguel's review or not review his um his
interview with Condrey is up already you
guys should definitely check that out
he he definitely said that they're gonna
they're focusing on like their PC
community and like making sure like
constant updates from me so I wouldn't
be too worried I think there might be
some bumps just because Call of Duty PCE
usually has some bumps I know the beta a
lot of people said it was a little bit
of a bumpy experience but just know that
sledgehammer is aware and that they're
doing things about it so I think that's
good I
if you've got a PC though you might as
well just play pub G let's be honest
here
oh damn they're all going up the side
here nice there's one nice ooh
stand up you might go see the guy like
like poking it out a little bit more at
least that would be my guys rank six can
you believe it rank six on our way to
the prestige
what is it 55 in this our boy that we
also can't say his name on twitch said
can we play zombies no I embarrassed
myself I'm gonna play zombies I'm done
with it I can't seem I can play
multiplayer great zombies I sucked I
don't know what it is maybe I'm a
scaredy cat maybe I just suck EADS
bollocks is what are you playing this is
this is war mode which they just
introduced the Call of Duty World War 2
it's like objective-based you kind of
push forward one team pushes for the
other team defense yep this in
particular is this the the storming of
Normandy it's kind of cool
although I have to admit the sniper
rifle sounds sick it certainly does
we're all [ __ ] excuse my French but I
missed that didn't miss it that time
though I know there's a guy behind this
I feel like nice yeah I don't know if
you guys know so I'm gonna MLG sniper as
I say Daniel uh oh this is a good
question
does the war game mode favor defense
side more so this one yes this one
favors defense it's big time it is
really hard to pushes the Allies will
CBS at halftime will switch to the other
team
yeah it's is they're hardcore for
multiplayer yes there is no yeah I think
it's up now maybe not on YouTube but
it's up on site right yep if you go to
site there is a hardcore site just
GameSpot calm
there is hardcore Nick you did pretty
well as 28 and 10 I think was the last
time I saw the score I think it was 28
and 10
but then the server's went down so I got
playing the game for quad kill but the
servers were down so you can't see my
final KD don't worry I hit the button to
show everyone because I it's is a pretty
good round
I was pretty pretty pleased with myself
one in the chat is say going to the same
spot every time
what do you want me to do alright fine I
was gonna defend you I was gonna say
that like of course it's going at the
same spot you've been picking them off
like flies
not flies picking on well the problem is
that everyone in the other side is using
those mgs and I can't get to him because
they're using them all so they haven't
even tried to take any of these you can
built you can come through these walls
oh so this is the other side which is
the budget billing oh here we go so
riveting stuff from this side now you
know I was staying on the other side oh
and assist you new nice Oh kill
so this is where do I be able to play
this on PCM otherwise pretty sure it
launches to nine nine
yeah you should be oh the preload now
get off the beach
oh he's gonna try to go here so make
someone watch it done kick I love that
movie so good I know he's coming I'd be
dead already
all right Nick you better be on top of
that leaderboard uh whoa no 314 kills 13
defends okay we stopped them from
getting through so now we'll be fighting
from the other side and you'll see how
goddamn difficult it is so would you
snipe here as well or do you think you
know it's tough because you want to kind
of rush the beach and get in so I'm
gonna try not but I could get I'm not
sure about ou0
what is it meantime oh god this is ugly
dang that's gonna go underwater damn all
three of those mgs are running up here I
could see why this would be good to
coordinate like me have one person as a
sniper like take out the mgs like the
other people just put forward notes I'm
scared
so that guy survived is this alright
good so we got a couple guys here I'm
going this way
oh all right so this is gonna blow
that's good
alright so he blew that so now we can
push into the promise those guys are
still in these energies don't think oh I
can't you through it yeah you can it's
just tough alright so hard getting all
the way up there already there's a flame
trooper kit oh nice people got in uh
Adam Johnson asks how does the prestige
system work and now that there are
classes instead of the picks pick ten I
don't know if you know this but so I
prestiged during the review event and it
just kind of reset me just like old
times and I got to pick a new class so
the first time I played through I played
as airborne and the second time I played
through I went as this sniper class
whatever that is scout what so what was
is how long did it take you oh god Nick
you blew it you blew it
now you two get to 55 or 50 or whatever
that f it is well we were playing all
day non-stop pretty much so
geez I think it took me our wise I have
no idea I know that we played shoot
trying to think of like our wise what it
might have taken as shabbir says it
already has an update question mark yeah
it's 2017 every games gotten update yeah
usually like eight gigabytes if you want
to play that game when you get it bad
yeah it is interesting games these days
were like you go you get the disk you go
to play and then get the wait an hour
for it to download
interesting they're saying you should
throw smoke grenades uh yeah I guess I
could equip this smoking in ha all right
so we're at 78% on B but no one has even
tried a shadow for to aid us how are you
playing already uh Activision gave us
advance copies for review purposes gene
and capture gameplay for a video things
of that nature
well we got him what couple days ago oh
yeah just like today I think on Monday
evening this guy probably knows I'm
going I already saw him yeah he's
sitting right there I'm screwed aren't I
get you when you get there give him the
old bayonet charge right yeah so this is
it definitely favors defense here is
there more maps in the full game this is
the full game there are three war
scenarios rewar scenarios or operations
operations I guess sure what the exact
number is four so I'm saying in the chat
twelve
[Music]
yes is not looking good for us damn
struggle boss curly passive healing
effect they didn't in a campaign so in
campaign you have to use a health pack
but in multiplayer it is just passive oh
this is hard without a sniper class I
can't hold my bro oh really that's a
class base I think so let me say Dan
yeah I can't hold my breath peace I'm an
airborne class or infantry I think yeah
I'm infantry watching this side KBB says
I'm so excited
well Nick is enjoying it quite a bit
stress it out it's not very good oh my
cha please man
get out of here gonna rage quit after
this we'll get to the last new mode and
then I think we've pretty much covered
it you guys no team you guys no team
deathmatch your stuff I guess there's
some new maps there we could show off
but war mode is the most unique Maps I
would say yikes
geumja bored around them like that with
someone I don't know have abilities
someone must i maybe that's a perk
because i was just using the jeez yeah
we we ain't go when nobody even got to
capture point ants crazy
do you need to capture both there just
one both BAM got a capture boat stuff we
got absolutely some oked well actually
you guys can decide in the comments
would you rather we played the last
version of war mode or should we happen
a different kind of multiplayer match to
end stream do you want us to go back to
zombies and I can step my game up should
we do either of those let us know what
you think I'll just let operation
Griffin load as long as operation
Griffin loads if it doesn't load on
Waymon uh well first one says zombies
but we'll see what other people think I
can't go back one step up my game
I see another zombies I see two zombies
dang these zombies alright Jake might
have to take the reigns if I stuck again
Oh pushes operation Neptune again anyway
so we don't want to do this again
alright zombies yeah that's weird
I've never seen a T double alright we're
doing zombies once we once we load in
we'll get out and do zombies I'll focus
on killing lesson objective I see one
search-and-destroy though
yeah certain destroy his fun gun games
fund don't dominations Super Mom B's so
is if you guys have ever played the ball
the ball game it's called gridiron
gridiron is super fun
getting many of me out here yes halo
it's essentially it is essentially
Grifball all right it's all race in our
minds what happened earlier in zombies
and you're gonna be all I see champagne
looks like someone some champagne some
champagne let's see hold on hold the bus
Oh local hold the bus hold on hold on
don't get too excited
I'm getting excited add controller for
split screen gonna be so great if this
word out please please please okay
fingers crossed boys and girls this
would be so much better if it's not just
me alone
guests press X to play let's go okay all
right here we go all right Sam but I'm
too hyped staying up to play at launch
I've been there before I've definitely
been there before all right I'm gonna be
Murray because I think she's a cutie and
then have you movie who's roastin I
think right the the Scottish guy yeah
seems like it
do I do I change my stuff soldier yes
all right so I don't have a lot of
experience with loadouts I've only used
so do you recommend let me give you some
breakdown so the first one obviously is
shell-shocked
so shell-shocked gives you like this is
the only thing I've used so I've only
used this one what are you using
I use the one right down from there I
use camouflage because that lets me be
non visible to the zone so that's what I
was trying to do when I died earlier it
was when I get completely surrounded I
double tap the triggers and then the
zombies can't see me and I can either do
objectives or I can kill so I think that
one's really good the one with the
bullets
let me check lets you fire even if your
weapons are empty yep it lets you keep
it's like an unlimited fire I think a
little bit I'm gonna do knock back knock
back pushes ever run away from around me
honest which pack mule I don't like pack
mule yep pack mule just means you can
have three guns I think that's only a
really valuable uh leader in the game
and especially when you're four player
what up coops you riot in the comments
in twitch how are you good to see you
okay so we were at this so let's just
say we were at this event right for let
me select mine you're good and then I'm
going to do meta right I'm gonna be
checking the chat here and they're
probably not as often but if you guys
have any questions please let us know if
you wait until like wave breaks I'll
probably check it more frequently is it
story based with an ending how much so
hit that and then pick which one you
want no I thought I did probably one of
the select ones down that you've made a
lot of custom dots okay alright cool
yes this is awesome I don't have to be
alone and embarrass myself anymore
whoo so I'm gonna try to guide us
through as far as we can the things that
I know there are a lot of rejected so
what I was saying earlier is we were at
this event right for three days and we
spent pretty much a whole day playing
zombies uh nobody finished it and I
asked the dev's they said have you guys
finish it and they explicitly said there
were only a few people on their dev team
that were able to finish it I'm curious
on what finishing it means though I'm
really curious what that means cuz like
I think there's like one zombie map you
can actually finish but like finishing
it isn't really zombies so this is a
story I get that there's other ones that
have been stories it's just like
all right can you play with any girl
characters Nick is a girl character yes
I am Marie the main protagonists were
right now what we're doing here is we're
looking for her brother one of the
weirdest things no you cannot
yeah it's Papa's head off varsity the
machine pistol so let's see we have
enough to open the door okay so you go
ahead and open the door I'm gonna
quickly run and do the knobs you keep an
eye on the zombies so if you guys want
to watch the top screen I'll do a lot of
the objective stuff and then Jake will
handle a lot of the combat since I'm no
bueno at that all right the first knob
so we need to bring power to this so we
can get into the sewer to get to the
generator so you can follow these wires
to the generator valves sometimes
zombies will pop out of that window it
scares the every living [ __ ] out of me
all right so there's one more valve and
it's over here so I'm gonna have to open
up one gate unfortunately okay that's
good you spend a little your mind - oh
shoot I have I get it I do some kills
one more kill and I should have right
here yeah oh there's a couple guys over
here I'll kill no kill and then I'll
have enough to get to that third ah see
this is great having two people all
right I have enough so I will quickly
open this area
so you'll see a lot of these two rival
horror kind of callbacks things pop out
zombies come from the floor zombies will
drop down from above they really do a
pretty fantastic job of not telling you
what's going on and like have some
pretty cool jump scares all right so
let's wait till we're towards the end of
wave three I'm gonna blow this and all
the runners will come out alright let's
see where are they gonna come from I'm
trying to see how I use my shovel for
someone in the chat is saying they can't
play this until they get their Xbox one
X I know I I feel like Assassin's Creed
I'm kind of waiting until the Xbox like
at my xbox one X play kind of want to
play this on Xbox one act I I am pretty
excited to the Xbox one X I won't lie I
didn't think I was and I convinced you
to get one he Jake kind of convinced me
and made me realize that it was time for
I was due for a new upgrade Xbox anyway
so so yeah that was my thing it was like
I had my xbox one since launch it was
really loud huge like hard to fit
anywhere alright it's time time to
upgrade and rather than getting the
exercise I save up a little bit more
rather than guess I figured I'd save up
oh yeah if the X humming waves until
it's done I don't think there's waves
until it's done right it's like there's
no objective so I bleed objectives the
waves just keep going alright ready I am
going to go ahead and blow this since
that guy's alive you're gonna get some
runners so back off
the gum so you'll know the runners are
coming because you'll be able to hear
them
it sounds like quads oh nice alright
alright let's get down there quick so
this is the sewer so if you have enough
you might want to get that perk there's
the all right power is on so now we can
open this oh you might have to open or
is it not available yeah all right now
let's stay up here for wave 4 and kind
of work our way down yet
I won't I won't lie with the studio
lights on right now it's the glare is
brutal
like people are saying it's very dark
having glare to play save the day I've
only played a bit dark this is going so
much smoother alright you're going down
ok I am coming with so I crushed him to
m1 quality box huh
all right careful let's try to leave one
alive all right so I'm gonna quickly
open this for the salt mine because we
need to get down there
so first step is starting the next step
I'm gonna let him stay alive so what
we're doing here is we're trying to
build the Tesla gun so this is the Tesla
gun station but it's missing the parts
so let's go ahead and we'll go down this
way first we'll head down to the morgue
and start our way there so let's quickly
run down to the morgue I've sprinting
now oh yes okay so there are two
switches I'm gonna make sure that you
are set with the first and then I will
go to the second switch because we have
to hit them at the same time how would
you do this by yourself oh you don't
have to them concurrently I don't think
well hope I'm actually not sure if we
have to I'm gonna go ahead and hit the
switch if I can find it alright here it
is okay so it is it's not a time so you
get there and you stay there and try to
keep that one zombie occupant oh no we
don't have enough to open the door
Sheila my wrinkle all right so there's
this there's a switch on the other side
but the door cost 1500 to get to so let
me do some killing so I can get enough I
mean use you stay bye would you stay by
that one cuz I remember where the other
one is okay how much do I need to open
this door
alright 1500 so that's it and then I'll
will coordinate one to question our
objectives more obvious or did you
figure these out all in Iran they aren't
more obvious but it does tell you what
you need to do but it doesn't like yes
well we need man the melee takes a
long-ass time
ammunation pretty soon I'm gonna go
ahead with the oh shoot
oh hell yeah um oh you are shoot damn
that was an easy wave that's because it
was one of those like in-between waves
oh shoot the bars down here too so I was
trying to get into this so objectives
are not abundantly obvious I kind of
have a little bit of an advantage since
I got to play extensively at the review
event so that's why I know where most of
the objectives are in about the first
hour and a half but unfortunately when
we get in about an hour and a half even
an hour and ten I don't know I it's all
a new to them alright so I am did you
build this we did we did that part is
easy we should be able to do that are
you good because I'm gonna good the word
I can
that may or may not be yeah you can help
out and then let's try to get with one
left alive I also have the medic class
so I have extra revives alright insta
kills on so try to keep one alive I'll
tell you if I see any - all right kill
one leave the O on you know one of the
things that makes it a little bit
difficult is that there's um there's no
counter in the corner anymore you know
how you could be like oh - left keep the
last one alive mmm there was an
encounter in the old ones oh there
wasn't alright so let me get to this
switch guys running now alright get to
switch screen watch you alright ready
three two one hit it
alright we did it so salt my door is
available to open let's both get up to
the top floor before wave seven starts I
got plenty revived so I'm good
try not to go
oh shoot your way down there alright see
you have 1500 so come on up come back up
oh I guess I can look at your silhouette
hello
oh [ __ ] there's two of them alright let
me kill these guys and then we can
alright quickly open the salt line door
cuz we're gonna want it this is now that
one right there so this is now a kill
objective so watch out there to be two
big ones that explode right here try to
shoot their backs they'll explode and
kill the guys oh shoot I am out of ammo
dang yeah let's get to the pea shooter
so keep pushing your way down you're
gonna get to a module down there it's
gonna look really creepy Oh God
you keep going keep going keep going
you're done oh boy yeah keep pushing
down keep pushing down come this way
whoo that was scary I got pinned pretty
hard all right so keep coming keep
coming
try to have them follow you because what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna activate this
ancient shrine and and so what we want
to do is we want to kill these guys in
the middle of the circle to charge the
shrimp okay so let them get into the red
circle and a gun let them get in here
and then oh god I'm pinned I'm okay or
if you can't get to me
if you can survive without me there oh
god run try to run up and let them just
come to you then like run back up where
you came from and let them funnel in
towards you just watch it back I'm sorry
Jake god I need a better gun because if
you can survive the wave then you can um
I'll just revive myself you know what I
should have self revives no way dude no
oh shoot you're gonna get me Oh bet your
ass I am that's my boy I need a big you
let's take a break on objective and just
we can get better guns so the pea
shooter is okay the little grease gun
fingers crossed
I gotta go big or go home I'm gonna
maybe if I oh god I was gonna try to get
the bar I'll keep this guy occupied oh
that's good toggle action shadi how much
it cost
hello nice alright save that uno mas
alright so let's get back down there and
let's this is a shield generator in here
on the top screen so for five hundred I
can get shields guide dish get this
shield alright let's get down here and
then maybe if we get overwhelming for
the jack-in-the-box is it just like
monkey bombs yes yes this guy should
wait till they get close and pop that
yeah well hopefully it doesn't disappear
watch if it starts blinking yeah come on
start wave let's see in it look alright
watch out they come out of these cracks
and my name is rafael oh I'm from Italy
cha rough fellow me chiamo Niklas I
should be in this dumb alright sick
that's me we got enough - all right
anyway I believe we fully charged it so
we should Oh God
these runners hate them
I'll save my camouflage for just in case
you go down hey scoot off till I'm
hidden I will revive because I'm out of
ammo
in general damn I am alright let's see
start one but Oh God
start weapon assembly process this is
mucho difficult so yeah the lights I'll
turn out now so we need to I'm gonna
quickly use the weapon box dang that
sucks
alright so we need to go down to each
specific let me first turn on the guy's
shirt craft transfer device so the guy
sure craft is powered by dead zombies so
I'm not gonna read this person's name
either but he wants to know did you guys
get the zombies figure is that only
collector's edition ie
you don't even know I'm not even sure if
we've been mailed the collector's
edition just yet alright so go ahead and
follow the authority laughs here the guy
guy dish crap it's down here
oh hi hello with you all right so let's
quickly run down to the right dish
whatever Oh God ie do not feel confident
because it is so dark that I cannot see
the school still
so again Oh what is that it could be
something you need I don't know just
gives us more I got it Oh God but I am
completely surrounded good oh this is
good
this'll do that'll do all right so we
need to get to the jolt machine which I
don't
you keep killing and let me check my
objective-c they don't fund it we tell
you so I think the guy touch thing is on
the other side yes so this is the so
kill them inside the circle again we
need to charge the guy Tish okay so as
we kill they will move
the mission of Jesus God and heaven help
me Duke Nukem
pardon my french this is hard spits been
alright so we're moving it by powering
it with dead zombies
oh no wait pan is complete what's this
we need to get it inside there so yes
miss your zombie clothes come closer
charging the old machine we are almost
at point charge
oh god I'm an idiot I was not paying
company thank you yeah I can't see
I'm get that evening you should be ready
Oh watch out watch out he brushes you
he'll rush you you want to try to get
behind him
ooh nice I might have done it watch him
he'll ignore you for a little second
it's when you shoot him that they start
to rush you are we good here can leave
we need to pick up the weapon part it
seems I can kill this guy all right let
me pick up the weapon part is that the
big guy yep so now we have to move we
have to move the machine again
hi chat we haven't been looking sorry
hoop shoe says protip stop going down so
much at Nick you know what goob why he's
got bullying me you know he does it to
me when you're not here always bullying
me I'm gonna quickly use the mystery box
watch out
oh we haven't used the whatchamacallit
have we a sniper are you kidding me
language it's charged this guy down to
the other half I ran out of ammo aha no
one can see me because I'm camouflage I
all right I'll do some killing balling
camouflage
let me go find that big one I'll kill
the big one like while he can't see me
[Music]
all right big ones down
dude camouflage is supa dank
and they're just falling to the sky
right now
I knew check it oh she's been an hour
and a half all right so after zombies
we'll probably in the stream so please
enjoy not just big guy won't think guy
so you guys played this game enough what
score do you think it would get
unfortunately we can't answer that yet
the review will be up oh god at 9 p.m.
Pacific I was alright survivor I was
super scared WTF he face 57 million for
3 million
oh cool
alright so we have to go get the we have
to get to the other thing which is down
the other side where's the bar neck I
don't remember what side oh you're
killing me what does this give us
increase melee damage so I'm scared
don't forget you have the
jack-o'-lantern yeah or whatever you
call it I use one Wow
hahaha I hate wave there Dean gets so
differed over to baby I'm actually going
up I can't see anything down here so I'm
going up to the top where I can't see I
was up camouflage as you go down
camoflauge II sorry chat for not
answering questions we promise we are
not neglecting you
we are just deeply engrossed in the
zombies I see someone asking for Meili
animation slower yes it is yeah I don't
like we are playing just for everyone
that is wondering we were playing on ps4
Pro we got the game a little early so
that's what we're doing we're just kind
of showing off some of the gameplay some
of the new features I keep shooting the
big guy thinking in just the regular
zombie and holy guacamole they just keep
coming
oh whoa he's self detonated alright
insta-kill oh you pick it up oh man just
leave me down
I'll just keep behind them damn he is
ah we did good
that was a lot further than I expected
us to get goop Shu says goes down on the
into much smack goob
you talk too much smack damn how do I
have more headshots than kills that's
where also we also revived each other
three times each we're even so anyway
that was Nazi Zombies if you guys scrub
back you can see some campaign a really
really poor showing of zombies on my
part we couldn't figure out split screen
some war mode multiplayer and then back
to zombies for a nice round wave 13 got
pretty far yeah so game comes out
tonight at midnight Eastern Time 9 p.m.
Pacific our official review Miguel's
written review will be up at 9 p.m. so
keep an eye on gamespot.com
and can't spots YouTube channel and
social group says nice job caring Jake
Thank You Man
but yeah make sure to subscribe to
GameSpot if you enjoyed this it really
helps us out and yeah thanks for tuning
in we'll be back tomorrow with another
stream I don't think we know what its
gonna be probably more Call of Duty yep
I know there is a big Cod stream with
some some other Pro gods are coming in
so that's okay interesting
but yeah thanks for hanging out with us
OB guys enjoyed the stream sorry I
sucked at zombies earlier and yeah we'll
see you guys next time don't forget we
stream at 11:00 a.m. Pacific bye